à noite 50% a tarefa já complica
conseguido subir no pau tur algo sem
quebrar o salto e nem tropeçar no
caminho e cair quando recebi a um
convite vai falar no tedx mandar uma
cartilha na cartilha dizia escreveu o
roteiro em sair muito e apresente outras
pessoas
escrevi o roteiro mas eu fiquei super
segura e resolvi assistir palestras do
ted acho que assistimos 80
todas as palestras foram inspiradoras e
e isso me chamou a atenção e todas as
pessoas que eu vi eram determinadas
apaixonados a conquistar alguma coisa
que elas achavam muito importante
e elas não desistiram em todos os casos
tinham pessoas pra elas falam com elas o
tempo todo não que não ia dar certo que
elas eram velhas mais do que elas não
tinham dinheiro para executar aquilo e
mesmo assim não desistiram e eu posso
garantir se eu tô aqui hoje com vocês é
porque eu também não existe
vamos lá vamos lá eu pulei esqueci de
mudar eu sou um pouco estava nada pode
mudar mais um favor a e ajudar o meu
filho meu filho é nesta que se formou
dois anos ele fez um filme pra conclusão
de curso dele um filme sobre minha filha
que é o documentário ea no filme ele foi
feita em casa uma coisa um pouco
informal a gente achou que o filme fosse
ser bacana imagina meu filho mas sim que
ser bacana e no final eles têm de ser o
filme mais de 50 principais ele ganhou
13 prêmios ao redor do mundo e eu
apareço no filme de pijamas em
maquiagens tabelado enfim ele falou que
me ajudado e apreço em casa com o
roteirista o amigo dele o león
aí o léo falou mas o da silva não não
vai dar lá é diferente tem que falar de
você
foi um processo que eu vou confessar a
vocês muito difícil falar da gente e eu
do palestra falou meu trabalho do ala já
muitos anos e é uma coisa que é natural
porque eu sei o que estou fazendo eu não
sei o que esteja fazendo da vida
mas falando da gente é muito mais
difícil e eu vou tentar
gostaria de conseguir fazer uma palestra
inspiradora
a gente demorou muito passado foi
bastante complicado
foi digamos um exorcismo que a gente fez
e eu vou tentar cortar um pouco da minha
história é eu sempre gostei muito de ler
e é uma das coisas que eu mais gostava
de fazer na infância até hoje é a
leitura que é uma coisa que acompanhou
minha vida inteira a quando era bem
pequeno de uma professora que ela leu um
pequeno princípio todo mundo brinque
pequeno príncipe é ela leu na sala de
aula
todo dia ela lhe um pouquinho e aquilo
me deixou tão ansiosa porque é tão
curiosa que não podia esperar a lei
o pequeno príncipe eu tive que ler eu
mesmo sozinha e pois acho que o quando
começou a paixão pela leitura a um livro
que me encantou quando era criança foi o
texto o menino do dedo verde é uma
história todo mundo conhece a ele é um
menino e ele tem um jardineiro que é o
seu bigode e achou borges na tudo pra
ele e ele não se conformava como em
alguns lugares existe a ordem em outros
lugares a desordem eo pai dele era muito
rico era dono dada em uma fábrica de
campeões eo texto transforma tudo o que
ele achava feio e flores inclusive os
ganhos do pai e kim
eu acho os livros transformadores é esse
minha estante de livros vamos né
isso é outra história quando era criança
eu queria ser cientista então todo mundo
acha que quer ser uma coisa não crescer
e eu queria ter diploma tem um uma
pessoa independente trabalhar viajar
conhecer o mundo e eu comecei a
trabalhar muito cedo
com 16 anos eu vi no jornal o anúncio da
desistência leves menina bonita que quer
subir na vida trabalhando fui lá como
record jornal fazer um gesto de natal
aos 16 anos e acabei ficando
fui trabalhar vendedora comecei a
trabalhar durante o dia e estudar de
noite
em 1985 foi prestar vestibular que fazer
biologia não passei aí no ano seguinte
fez cursinho porque ele inventa que eu
queria fazer engenharia genética louca
né
também não passei no vestibular entrei
no rio blog as artes plásticas do
mackenzie
mas eu também não sei vestibular porque
os 19 anos eu fiquei grávida
grávida pedir emprego aí não podia mais
pagar a faculdade teve que parar de
estudar
de certa maneira fiquei aliviada porque
eu fiquei com vergonha de ter ficado
grávida
enfim fui quanto à minha mãe que eu
fiquei grávida minha mãe ficou louca
comigo e ela falou não você vai ter que
dar um jeito fazer alguma coisa foi mãe
não queria casar mas eu também não
queria fazer um aborto não a china que
vergonha
você tinha que casar virgem a lei no
entanto amor de deus ea virgem maria
engravidou imagina eu que não era santo
não dava pra fazer milagre
é muito complicado eu lembro é que eu
engravidei a gente é aniversário do meu
namorado está fazendo 23 anos ea gente
saiu fomos no site que acompanha a
choperia e era uma festa de reatamento
das relações diplomáticas entre brasil e
cuba e assim música caribenha shows é
galeão e itamar assumpção isca de
polícia cuba livre
depois da festa eu fiquei grávida gente
grávida de gêmeos de dois bons os gêmeos
de repente casada com 20 anos dois
filhos morando no apartamento vazio e
não tinha nem telefone
eu ficava sozinha o dia inteiro os
meninos da sede da manhã até meia noite
e foi uma fase muito difícil porque eu
não sabia fazer nada não tinha
experiência
mas eu aprendi e os meninos ele eram
muito fofinhos os queridinhos e quando
ele crescer um pouquinho a final do ano
que fazer um gesto de natal
voltei a trabalhar e acabei ficando
voltei a trabalhar porque precisava
ajudar a pagar as contas a gente não
tinha nem armário do apartamento não
tinha nada e há também ajudar o meu
marido pagar a factura direito ea gente
combinou que depois que terminasse a
faculdade dele eu ia voltar a estudar e
assim minha vez
só que na formatura dele estava grávida
jogo contra o barrigão desse tamanho
dessa vez eu tinha certeza que uma
menina eu conhecia luiza já antes dela
nascer já tinha dado o nome tinha uma
paixão eu sabia que ela ia ser loirinha
sabe que ela tem olho azul
só que a gente teve complicações a no
final da gestação ea gente teve um parto
antecipado ea luiza o médico falou que
ela ia não ia sobreviver e mas ela
sobreviveu à luz hoje tem 26 anos e ela
tem algumas sequelas
diante das dificuldades da luiza eu tive
que adiar meus planos de estudar
novamente e meu marido vai fazer uma pós
graduação
ele acabou fazendo duas porque o
desenvolvimento da luta foi bastante
lento
e eu lembro que tinha uma terapeuta logo
no começo que ela falava que tinha cinto
não que você tem um problema e todo dia
tinha terapia ela não porque o problema
é que ele foi me me deixou tão nervosa
que a gente não tem problema eu tenho um
monte de problema tenho vários
imagina você que eu tinha que cuidar da
luiza dos gêmeos da casa trabalhar levar
os meninos na escola e aloísio na
terapia todos os dias e aquilo me
sufocou e um dia eu falei não chega não
quero mais essa terapeuta vou mudar
mudei de terapeuta a contra gosto do meu
marido mas se foi a melhor escolha que
eu fiz
a doutora news que é terapeuta da luiza
era totalmente diferente é o super
animada amorosa e ela comemorava comigo
toda conquista da luiza luiza demorou
pra andar
ela não andava então a gente acabou
colocando a na notação pra ver se ela
desenvolvia e foi ótimo porque
desenvolvemos 14 natação ela aprendeu
nada antes de andar e ajudou também a
coordenação motora dela dona nilce
também de compra a gente já fono o
geólogo a doutora eliana maravilhosa
super animada também e ela inventou
inúmeras formas da luiza se comunicar
por que a lusa não falava nada
com seis anos a a terapeuta da escola
chamou a gente olha falo isso não fala
nada só tem seis anos a criança depois
da sociedade nos envolve mais ela nunca
vai falar assim mal sabem eles hoje que
a luiza é uma tagarela não pode falar em
quando a gente pede assim uma coisa que
é fora de série
enfim quando estava um pouquinho maior
zinha eu falei agora eu acho que chegou
a hora de voltar a estudar e falei pro
meu marido vamos lá eo óleo
eu acho que isso não é uma boa hora
porque eu tenho outros planos que esses
planos não incluíram e ele foi embora
porque a gente separou a iv com 33 anos
em três filhos sem profissão e
recomeçando a vida de novo entrei em
depressão lógico do mundo numa fase
dessa passa mal e eu a procurei uma
terapeuta terapia ea doutora ângela era
ótima forma que a depressão é uma forma
de negação como agente nega alguma coisa
a gente entra em depressão e ela pediu
pra mim um livro que é maravilhoso
mulheres que correm com os lobos a quem
não leu eu recomendo que leia tinha um
conto a pele de foca e o homem ele se
apaixona pelo olhar da foca e conforme
ele tira veste da foca ela se revela uma
mulher maravilhosa e ele se apaixona
roubar aparelhos foca dela esconde e
casa-se com ela e ela cuidar dele e
cuida da casa e se tem filhos e ela
esquece de quem era foi a com o passar
do tempo
um dia ela arrumando a casa encontra
dentro de um baú a pele da foca e aí ela
lembra de quem foi e ela pensa nos
filhos
só que ela vai até a beira do mar ela
não resiste ao chamado
ela veste a pele de foca e vai embora
quando chegou e as férias do trabalho eu
tenho uma prima que mora na frança e ela
me ligou a roupa tem pra cá já foi como
assim não posso não se pode sim larga
tudo aí vem pra cá comigo passa o ano
inteiro aí quer saber que eu deixei os
filhos com o pai e vestir a pele de foca
e fui embora
lá foi a paris comprei um cartoon range
comprei um mapa e lá em paris eu me
encontrei foi maravilhoso adorei a
viagem no meio um passo de 7 de museu
tomei um banho de cultura inclusive em
paris eu me apaixonei e loucamente mas
isso é uma outra história fica para
outro dia a gente vai falar de educação
enfim voltei felicíssima de paris uma
ideia louca que eu queria estudar é
fazer um curso de arquitetura medieval
na frança doida é comentei com uma amiga
minha que eu queria fazer esse curso é
bom
silvino viaja loucas nunca vai acontecer
em bateu no meu ego falei gente que a
amiga que é isso magoou e lembrei que
meu pai sempre falava silvia não se
magoe pelo caráter dele a lei ou se você
tem uma idéia não seja se jogar no poço
também mandou siga sua vida
então fui lá era o primeiro acho que eu
tenho que tomar na vida de matrícula na
faculdade 35 anos me matriculei no curso
de arquitetura e vou fazê lo e aí eu
pensei meu pai era engenheiro e gente
não vai ver isso é normal já que o teto
é que vou falar pra ele como fazer
arquitetura
no final foi contra o meu pai que eu
entendo cuja arquitetura e ficou
supercontente imagina a partir de 80
anos e e para ele era uma jovem cheia
mais a estudar ele é um querido e ele
sempre me ajudou a fazer a lição de casa
inclusive me ajudou a fazer os trabalhos
da faculdade e foi maravilhoso
muita gente falou que não ia dar certo
com uma velha que me informar com 40
anos que era perda de tempo mas eu sigo
em frente me formei e eu preciso
agradecer porque eu me formei graças à
minha sogra o marido era ruim mas a
sogra é maravilhosa ea fátima sempre me
ajudou ela foi demais ela cuida da minha
filha com amor é assim como se fosse uma
mãe e eu vou ter que pedir para vocês
deram uma salva de palmas to be a sogra
porque ela merece
[Risadas]
[Aplausos]
em 2006 eu me formei em arquitetura e
urbanismo
aí eu fui lá que ir pra paris na frança
né
é me inscrever no curso de mestrado da
da usp
eu assisti um semestre como o 20 e eu
queria no curso patrimônio histórico
aí o professor falou em que eu não tinha
currículo pessoal na usp podem desistir
nós vamos lá irá desistir do mestrado e
engraçado como a vida tem algumas
conexões
meu pai é engenheiro eletricista e ele
fazia projeto de iluminação e eu arrumei
o meu timing arquiteto o emprego numa
empresa de iluminação e eu fui muito
bacana a última chefe a rosângela é
muito assertiva
e ela era muito exigente também mas me
ensinou a ter foco foi ótima e ela sabia
que era esforçado eu queria estudar e
ela sugeriu que eu fizesse a
pós-graduação e ela pediu para a empresa
pagar esse curso eles pagaram aí fez
após a versão de pós-graduação e
iluminação e foi maravilhoso fazer após
porque pra mim foi um divisor de águas
eu já trabalhava com iluminação e me
ajudou no meu trabalho com soluções
práticas foi muito importante e se essa
fase da minha vida fiz uma pesquisa em
2010 para a conclusão do curso sobre a
fisiologia da luz
ah eu publiquei esse artigo em 2011 que
a luz mais saúde na época da pesquisa
time a orientadora falou que era um
pouco esotérico tema mas eu insisti e
publiquei em 2012 com meu diploma de
pós-graduação eu comecei a dar aula
de lá pra cá e vendendo dando aula am em
vários lugares inclusive na falha a e
nesse mesmo na mesma fase os meus pais a
foi uma fase que ele está doente eu tive
meus pais tiveram alzheimer
tanto meu pai quando minha mãe e foi uma
fase muito difícil você ver como as
pessoas é definir e eu tenho uma vontade
muito grande de passar meu conhecimento
adiante porque eu vejo que essa doença
ela acaba tirando da gente muitas coisas
você esquece das pessoas depois você
esquece das coisas e no final você
esquece da sua história e é um muito
difícil e eu tenho medo de perder minha
memória também porque a irmã esperamos
ainda tem pessoas que talvez eu também
tenha em 2016 eu fiz outra pesquisa
dessa vez sobre o impacto da da luz
na natureza os animais essa pesquisa
enviei pra começar do iémen surge
energia e ambiente da usp mas também não
ganha a vaga mas eu publiquei essa essa
pesquisa ea na publicação eu desenvolver
um protótipo uma hipótese ned um
espectro de luz seja mais adequado à
natureza e um fabricante investiu no
protótipo
e aí eu publiquei nas redes sociais
alguns testes algumas fotos alguns
comentários sobre a pesquisa e um
pesquisador da inglaterra
é isso chama a atenção do meu trabalho
enviou e mail artigo pra austrália o
doutor a kelly ela entrou em contato
comigo e pediu se poderia usar as minhas
ilustrações numa apresentação que ela
fez no início deste mês em utah nos
estados unidos que é um congresso
internacional sobre o uso artificial de
ver gente igual civil artigo foi
relevante a ponte ser exposto no
congresso internacional
a pesquisa é muito boa e assim eu acho
uma pena que a gente tenha poucas
oportunidades né
e eu penso será que porque eu sou mulher
se ela aqui porque eu sou mais velha de
onde vêm essas oportunidades ea eu acho
que no final eu realizei meu sonho de
menina independentemente do que as
pessoas pensem que eu queria ter o
diploma e cientista eu acho que eu
conquistei e eu a quando a gente quer
alguma coisa a gente tem que insistir no
assunto a gente não deve se encontrar
com o que os outros falam ah a gente tem
as oportunidades a gente tem que agarrar
a oportunidade de seguir em frente
eu acho que deus não é um homem de deus
é uma mulher é uma deusa é a natureza é
perfeita é fecunda e feminina e ela dá ó
pra gente tudo o que a gente precisa
então meninas
a gente já tem desde ter toda tecnologia
sé necessário para tornar o nosso mundo
sustentável ea gente também não precisa
de tanta riqueza financeira a gente já
tem muito dinheiro no mundo para poder
executar muita coisa
a maior riqueza que a gente tem são as
pessoas o convívio das pessoas é a união
é a família é o apoio de todas as
pessoas
então meninas estudem porque o futuro
está em suas mãos
obrigada
tenho 50 segundos é meus filhos gente o
casamento não errou mas filha tudo de
bom
luiza é minha filha ela é como texto ela
tem a capacidade de transformar o mundo
tudo que ela toca vila flor o thales meu
filho fugiu e sua pele de foca dele mora
na austrália porque ele queria ser
professor de futebol está há três anos
lá se divertindo liberdade e o caio que
fez cinema ele retrata o mundo quantas
histórias aí pra todo mundo
obrigada
[Aplausos]